I took my daughter bowling a few weeks
ago on a Friday night and I checked into
the bowling alley on four squared and
said oh special here my other was a
special and it said basically for
checking in and get two-for-one bowling
so did that and sent me to go to the
bowling alley know my daughter wanted to
go to the bullying out but did we stay
longer yes and therefore did I have
another beer probably you know so you
know they gave me a free free game of
bowling that doesn't there's no
incremental cost for that right you know
some marginal electricity or whatever
there was nobody waiting for that alley
and you know we were there but if they
had known or if you would have known
beforehand of the special yeah then
maybe you would have brought a friend
right right right right now i can assure
and then they use twitter to so maybe I
did know if this guy kept every one of
the funniest part of that whole story is
that when I went to get the 241 and I
showed the woman what would it set up
she's like what is that I'm like it's
foursquare somebody here must know what
it is because you guys put the special
out here just like oh well okay if you
have a coupon for two for one that's
fine I'm like it's not a coupon and it's
a Foursquare thing but that's the only
term is she knew how to relate to it so
not everybody's kind of there yet but I
think my daughter ate understood more of
what I was trying to do then the woman
selling bowling shoes or whatever
absolutely interested but that's
actually really interesting so if you
had two innocent and know you talked at
it and large but i'm looking for a short
snippet the calendar of future is or
does i think the cat will start to start
with the calendar of the future yeah
like say there is rest look it is there
deep from the calendar the future helps
you decide what you want to accomplish
rather than drives your day for you
that's really for me the key is
understanding what you're working on
what's going on in your social network
what's going on in your personal life
and gives you the information for you to
decide intelligently how you're going to
be successful in any
okay excellent very cool all right you
think we covered is there anything you
think we should didn't deep groan we've
covered we've talked a bit about
analytics and data and so on yeah the
only topic we didn't talk about which is
interesting given what you guys do is
free top the concept of free time okay
because it is still such a pain in the
ass in enterprise calendaring you guys
solved part of the problem at least and
when I pitched on goal in my you know
public presentations whatever I I always
start with the if I want to have a
meeting with you mr. customer what do we
do right now we sent a bunch of emails
around and get our secretaries involved
everybody tries to figure out when
they're available oh wait no that
person's on vacation it's just such a
huge profits problem within the four
walls of most organizations and it's a
hundred times more complicated because
the lack interoperability outside the
organization and so I think free time
you know we thought we solved it pretty
early on with nodes we made a
centralized database into that
information offline but you know I see
people within IBM now using tumble
because it's just an easier metaphor to
say let me say what time I have
available and we'll figure out what's
best for everybody there's too many
people and in the two years I've been
executive I've learned this feel like if
they go to schedule a meeting and they
hit that free type search button and
your time shows available they're
entitled to that time that kills me it
is just unbelievable the presumption
that I get and you know I'm happy to
meet with almost anybody and I'd be able
to talk about a customer and that's what
I'm there for but let's make sure it
fits with my workflow where I'm at that
day maybe I'm free in that time to have
a conversation in the car but if you're
trying to schedule a meeting where you
want me to look at charts it's not going
to work but you don't know that because
all your see if it's that little free
block of comment
so I think that one of the problems that
still had to be addressed and I think
tumbles gone further than anybody else
is how do we make that free time concept
effective and useful not just oh look
there's a block of time and you must
face this because your calendar on
tunngle makes you appear to be available
monday afternoon to friday morning but
you're clearly not okay right so you're
helping people with a there's no barrier
to get to you but once they try they
have to work with you on what's really
available you know that that's actually
a very interesting evolution of how we
evolved and things that we're actually
implementing in addition for example
when we first started we thought okay we
want we always thought we want to solve
the scheduling problem that that from
the inception of the company this is the
pain we're so but then when so then was
alcohol we need to counter sharing and
calendar sharing doesn't solve the
problem you know calendar sharing gives
you information calendar sharing does
not solve it's not because I'm busy then
I'm not free to meet you and it's not
because I'm free that I'm ready to meet
you it's like it depends on the context
of what I'm doing so at one point we
said okay well let's let's try to do it
so that people can propose multiple
times and give the choice so so so the
idea was without knowing whether you're
free or not let me propose multiple time
and let people pick and that was great
but then it was like hold on there is
some valuable information in this
calendar thingy okay so let's say I
leverage that so then we started to do
and we showed free/busy to people and we
quickly realized that at the end of the
day people didn't care about data like
didn't I think I didn't want to know
when you were busy actually I don't even
want to know what you're doing I want to
know when you're free to meet me right
that's what I'm trying to do right like
I don't care what you do it and so we
flipped our thing around now it's
available yeah and you get to set the
parameters of when you want it and then
with time what we will do is that
on the type of people you may have
different types of profile that you want
to share with different people as well
as you need to take into consideration
while I'm meaning this i'm available
here but it depends for what like this
one because i'm traveling maybe it's
just a phone call maybe you know and so
it really depends on the context of what
you're doing so we're going to add some
contextual stuff to your availability so
that you when people go to book a
meeting with you they'll know that i
guess you can book it there because he's
traveling get remember and so those this
is the evolution will start doing so
yeah absolutely yeah it's a it's an
interesting problem to solve and we're
having fun yeah yeah i mean i look at
you know my day-to-day routine right now
and my normal assistant is out on
vacation this week so i'm working with
somebody who didn't who isn't into
rhythm with me right I'm not it's still
gonna understand how you use your yeah
and so the first day she left my
calendar she actually ping me and she
said your calendars a mess I've like no
it's not but on my calendar I have from
eight to nine every day this week
blocked for my daughter to get on a bus
right because that is my time that I
need at home to get her you know on her
way and so she brings me with it can you
do a seven a.m. call and I'm like know
if my daughter's here and I gotta get
her out of the bus between 8-9 I got to
get her fed and watered and showered and
everything else between seven and eight
but if it's a week that she's not going
to camp or she's not with me in my eyes
then sure I would do a seven o'clock all
right so we're not in that rhythm yet so
is that and then i block my calendar at
noontime every day so that it doesn't
show up is free and being free time
search me not because I want to take an
hour for lunch every day that's I can't
remember the last time that happened
then right other than a meeting like
today but because I want time to catch
up an email I want time to just be able
to stop and think and not just have call
after call after meeting after meeting
all day and so she didn't understand
what those were for my normal assistant
knows sometimes I'll think a call in
that out right if it's really important
she'll help me work through that but
normally that is just I don't you
right absolutely and that it was oh well
they want to do this face-to-face
meeting in Chicago when can you do that
it looks like you're available and this
assistant she was so funny she's like
well I took your home address and the
address where the meeting is and it's
you know 32 miles and says it'll take 47
minutes to get there so a block an hour
in front she thought she was being
really proactive and helpful I said well
actually for that location i would take
the train and the train leaves at
twelve-thirty not at one so I actually
needed another half hour she's like oh
so it's not the trains not as fast as
driving I said well but traffic time you
got from google maps yeah that's not
real yeah if I could get there driving
in 40 minutes yeah and I probably would
but not at that time of day in Chicago
so it was this fascinating sort of
rhythm of what does she need to do
around me having an actual physical at
home meeting which I don't do that often
right because either i'm on a plane and
i'm on the road or i work at home right
this I BM facility buried right now as I
said to be walking it I've never been
here I've been here twice before I work
at home and my rhythm around that is
very different that my boss who works in
an IBM facility you know since it a
cubicle has it right next to him you
know goes to conference rooms for
meetings but at that whole world isn't
my world so you know the calendar is the
same but it's not really missing
absolutely absolutely i mean yeah i've
i've had once been assistant for about a
month like that I'm gonna do my so yeah
it's like the easier yes and it was not
a ton below me was in a previous life
but in
like a is to train someone to understand
how I want to use my time like I'd
rather build the tool the skies are hip
done yeah there you go so let me turn
the camera cam yeah but yeah I still
don't have my assistant get involved
because it's just it's not that I don't
want the help i jus desperately want
that but there's so many nuances to the
way that I work and she has to support
other people too cool at some point you
get it important enough that you have to
do it absolutely so I think we're good
unless there's something else I think
we've covered so privacy analytics
calendar future visualization we talked
about I mean one of the one of the
chapters that the manifesto is you know
life optimization like how how will all
this stuff that we're talking about make
your life easier and at the cute you
gave some good examples of that we
talked about the past I think we're good
cool they're the restroom and we can
talk about whatever else and we go to
lunch early here or whatever it we've
been in this the ten work mom Gail so
okay so foursquare did no I just didn't
know where I am